Wake up and make yourself a hardcore breakfast
of skull-shaped eggs.
To go along with your death wish coffee.
Because LÜT is back!
If you're unsure if you have eggs make sure
to grab one of these Eggminder Smartphone
connected trays that let you check your egg
level on the go and even sends alerts when
you're running low.
Don't worry about overeating with this sugar
skull spoon that reminds you how evil sugar
can be while you're adding it to coffee and
tea.
Or use it to add Caffeinall to your favorite
foods.
Sprinkling it on your favorite foods is like
drinking a cup of coffee so you can finally
make energy pizza!
If you'd rather just smell food take a whiff
of Fried Chicken with this scents of the commonwealth
candle.
Then set the mood with these Star Wars mood
lights.
While you impress everyone and turn water
into wine with this handy kit that comes with
everything you need to make a bottle of wine
in less than three weeks.
If you've had too much wine make sure your
kids have this wearable smart locator called
Filip that allows parents to keep in touch
with their kids on the go.
With it kids aren't stuck having to carry
around a phone and parents are able to call
or text a watch to get in touch.
But if you don't have any kids you can just
track your pets instead.
Like my dog, Lucy.
Hi Lucy!
If you feel more comfortable taking care of
something not living and breathing the Spiri
is a programmable flying robot designed just
for you.
It was recently funded on Kickstarter and
hope that Spiri can be a reporter, cartographer,
playmate, or inspector.
Ignore electricity with this pop out outlet
from Adorne that allows you to hide your outlets
when not in use by simply popping them in
or out.
If you prefer natural power try using the
Hydrobee that powers your USB devices using
the energy in rivers, streams, faucets, or
even while being towed behind a boat.
Then use it to light up your desk with this
Kinetic Light Newtons Cradle.
Or your tail...... lights.
Circuit Stickers are small flexible circuit
boards with anisotropic conductive adhesive
on the back that are compatible with any conductive
material.
The creators want to bring electronics and
crafts together giving people the ability
to easily make cool interactive projects.
Or just use Circuit Scribe and draw your circuits
instead.
Then relax in your ridiculously epic skull
chair for some light reading.
Like this book of calculus for infants.
For something a little more grown up flip
thorough this pop up book of phobias that
showcase your deepest fears like snakes, spiders,
dirty toilets, and heights.
When you're done reading your books put them
on this balance book shelf that helps you
visualize what you've already read and what
you have left.
And really tie the room together with this
monster skin rug.
Along with your whimsical Wobbly furniture.
Now check your watch and do some math to figure
out what time it is because we're almost done.
And all that's left to do is scream into this
stress reduction shouting vase.
And as always.... thanks for watching!